my multimedia american cockroach project
which includes photography five short
films
drawing and sculpture was a 10-year
investigation into our adversarial
relationship with nature yes i raised
cockroaches for 10 years
because i could think of few animals
more hated
than the roach yet for me it was a
conduit
to the negative and often violent
tendencies we have
towards the animal world paraplaneta
americana
the most common domestic roach species
is no longer found in the wild it has
moved in
with us i documented the roach's life
eating drinking sex birth
molting in its now native habitat
our home as with all my projects
i work with the animals natural behavior
they are my collaborators i watch
respond experiment and adjust
through this back and forth process my
artwork takes shape
how do you work with a cockroach how do
you navigate the same space
without mutual terror and chaos
you think we hate them they are wildly
afraid of us
it's possible to frighten a roach to
death
10 minutes in the state of panic and it
can die of the equivalent of a roach
heart attack
did early homo sapiens find the
cockroach as detestable as we do now
certainly they had more dangerous
animals to fear
i think our hatred of the roach has
grown as we
increasingly wall ourselves off from the
natural world
trespassers will be prosecuted
what are the aesthetics of our empathy
towards animals
would we like the cockroach better if it
had spots like a ladybug
or was fuzzy like a bumblebee or was
dawned with colorful feathers
like a bird of paradise people seem to
prefer
animals that are soft and furry as
opposed to hard and shiny
animals with big eyes as opposed to thin
antennae
but what do these qualities have to do
with the animal's importance to the
ecosystem
it points to the subjectivity perhaps
arbitrariness
of how we think about animals in general
yet these aesthetic preferences have
real consequences
all cultures have systems for
classifying and organizing
the natural world and such rankings are
rarely neutral or objective
these taxonomies determine our emotional
response towards different species
and even entire classes of creatures
they also underlie our many
environmental policies
my cockroaches were disguised as insects
in a garden
looking pretty pollinating flowers
the idealized vision of nature
but most insects are predators savagely
ripping apart fellow insects
or in the case of the cockroach
recycling waste
and debris humans have a bias against
scavengers
and that the american cockroach can
successfully scavenge off of us
further further fuels our hatred of them
and what we don't like we tend to kill
though not usually by hanging a gas
chamber
burning at the stake or electric chair
death ties us to the roach in a unique
way
we kill them they survive we kill
ourselves
they survive my executions were enacted
with already dead bugs
this series is not about the suffering
humans have endured at the hands of
humans but what other species have
endured
because of us it's easy to keep abuse on
creatures whose lives are alien and
whose biology and behaviors
seem bizarre and decidedly non-mammalian
yet without insects the terrestrial
ecosystem
would crash in a matter of months
and how do we repay them for supporting
us
by hating them the cockroach is
emblematic of the questions we face
as we struggle to decipher our
relationship to the animal world in
general
what do we love what do we kill what do
we save and what goes extinct
my artistic career has been focused on
one central issue
how to confront and challenge our
human-centric point of view
we have been drawing lines in the sand
forever maybe now at the dawn of the
anthropocene
is a good time to reconsider those
divisions and what lives
on the other side thank you